How might you be able to differentiate between
the executives who ultimately decided to commit
fraud and those who didn't?
You look at all these incentives and over
a 20 year period there's thousands of executives
who have strong incentives from their career
perspective, from the value of their stock
options to inflate the numbers, and only a
tiny fraction, you know, less than one percent,
that we know of, ever wind up doing this.
So maybe there's something unique that we
can find about these people.
We started brainstorming and thinking about
just anything about someone's lifestyle, beliefs,
personal behaviors that might be relevant
in this area.
And we had a list of all sorts of things like
if they had extramarital affairs or we thought
about trophy wives or just anything.
And some of the things were more just sort
of joking around.
But then we had a list of things that we thought
would make good sense.
One of them was if an executive had previously
broken the law.
Another one would be the relative materialism
or frugality of an executive; how they spend
their money.
And it turns out that we're able to get pretty
good data on these two things for a large
number of senior executives.
So instead of just having an idea, it's actually
something that we can test.
So in this paper we found that executives
who had previously broken the law were maybe
two and a half to three times more likely
to commit accounting fraud in the analysis
we did.
What was perhaps a little more surprising
was that if we looked at executives whose
only legal violation was a minor speeding
ticket or some other traffic violation, we
still find significant results.
Now, they're definitely weaker but they're
still meaningful and significant in the tests
that we run.
We go one step further.
When the SCC investigates a firm they usually
name the people that the evidence suggests
specifically perpetrated the fraud.
And when just looking at who the SCC actually
singled out, we found those with these prior
legal violations were six to seven times more
likely to be the one the SCC indicates had
actually committed the act.
The second characteristic we looked at, depending
on what area of say psychology or sociology
you're looking at, you can think about it
as either frugality or materialism, they're
roughly two sides to the same coin.
I mean if you live a really frugal lifestyle,
you're not really materialistic, and if you're
really materialistic you're not frugal.
So we were able to get pretty good data on
cars, boats and real estate that an executive
owns.
Ideally we'd have paintings or huge diamonds
or something of that sort but you really can't
accurately collect data like that for a large
group of people.
So we came up with just a binary measure whether
we treated an executive as frugal or materialistic
or unfrugal depending on the value of any
vehicles they owned, the length of any boats
they may have owned and then sort of an excess
value of their real estate.
We realized there's a cost to living.
People need to pay to live.
And depending on where an executive works
that cost can vary dramatically.
So we wound up basically subtracting the average
cost of living for wherever they happen to
be and we said if an executive's home was
more than double what the average is, we'd
consider that relatively unfrugal.
We'd found some interesting research that
suggested frugal CEOs placed more emphasis
on controls and on monitoring.
And we thought strong monitoring and good
controls probably reduces the likelihood that
fraud takes place.
So we didn't find a really strong theory to
suggest that these materialistic CEOs would
commit fraud themselves, but we thought it
was reasonable that if they weren't placing
emphasis on controls that somebody in the
firm might do it.
And that's really what we found.
We didn't find that these materialistic CEOs
were accused specifically by the SCC of committing
fraud, but we found fraud was much more likely
to happen at their firms.
And then just as a follow up we thought well,
if this really is related to corporate governance
broadly or firm controls and monitoring, then
these CEOs should also be more likely to have
to restate financial statements just because
of an error.
So we collected data on restatements that
were not intentional and basically performed
the same analysis and we found they were more
likely to have errors take place at their
firms.
So we think this has to do with a culture
that they set in the firm and the relative
lack of emphasis on monitoring and controls.